when you each walked into the werk room
on that day and saw which other queens
were in that workroom tell me who your
biggest competition was at that moment
and why [ __ ] walk into the workroom
looking around honestly I really look to
India first because she was the person
in the room that I knew the least about
on a personal level so when you don't
know somebody you don't know something
that inherently is kind of scary and
then I also was really intimidated by
Shay as well but when Ongina walked in
with her look I can definitely tell you
that my head turned and I was kind of
like oh okay
all right girls I was like oh she the
game okay sorry I was stuck in traffic
the Feder of other competitors didn't
sink in to me
until I saw the talent show a variety
show and that's when I looked at every
single one of these talented ass [ __ ]
and I was like you india 2.0 here
remodeled remastered and ready for
action
the two that caught my eye immediately
was Blair and Shay
but as Blair said when angina walked in
I said oh so the girls are coming
hardcore this is going to be a full-out
competition we know all-stars always has
a few twists and turns so when you found
out that there was gonna be a lip-synch
assassin brought back did your job just
completely drop punch out the jaws
dropped yeah
my jaw my jaw dropped because I was so
confused I had no idea what was really
happening until it the first lip-sync
assassin actually happened so I'm
sitting there with my blonde self like
I've covered your story before on et
Canada bride and you know I think you
had one of the most emotional
eliminations in drag race history
my first
experience I was raped at a college
party and from that I look to find
pretty things do you think that moving
forward has helped you become a better
drag queen I think that sharing my truth
on season 10 of RuPaul's Drag Race was
the very first step and initially
figuring out who I am and allowing
myself to freely be myself I think that
I had for so long felt so guilty for
feeling like a victim of something that
had happened to me that was the first
moment that I began my journey and not
feeling like a victim anymore but
beginning to feel like a survivor I love
that so moving forward now into
all-stars 5 what are we gonna be seeing
from Blair st. Claire well let me ask
you this what do you not expect to see
because you're about to see a little bit
of everything
honey all the spices mixed in I'm gonna
give you looks I'm gonna give you a
little bit of comedy yes she can be kind
of funny I'm also gonna give you acting
singing dancing I'm gonna give it all to
you because I am putting everything into
all-stars for that crap so what is
version 2.0 of india ferrah well leaving
season 3 and just being known for simply
being picked up drag is not a contact
sport that has put so much pressure on
me over the years and going to bookings
and show up the show and having those
fans constantly remind me of one of the
worst moments of my drag career it was
very hard to come back from that and
rebuild my character and rebuild India
but growing up and maturing over the
years and evolving my drag into this
huge fabulous fantasy character that I
am it's exciting to be able to show that
instead of just being known as the girl
who got picked up or the horrible
weather girl and on Jonna you were on
season 1 which is crazy that was 11
years ago how are you going to step into
all-stars 5 and really
yourself and take that crown I think
I'll do that with the same genuine
Ongina that you saw in season one just a
little bit better a little bit more
evolved a little bit more precise to
what I now see as Ongina as a drag queen
things may change and look more
expensive but true real Ryan Ongina will
be the heart and soul but you're gonna
see from me in this season jayna essence
all of course just one her season
congratulations to Jada that one and
Congrats Jada Congrats to Jada what I
noticed about season 12 was there wasn't
a lot of drama and I personally don't
watch drag race for the drama that's not
my I thought my gig I'm not a tabloid
kind of guy I'm there to watch Queens
excel and do incredible things is there
gonna be drama in all-stars 5 or are we
gonna have friends just a pinch ya
answer that question I love her too much
oh hey there if you want more LGBTQ news
and exclusive interviews click Subscribe
or watch these videos